New York Governor Andrew Cuomo escapes
responsibility for New York's disaster
as Mayor Bill DeBlasio slams the Jewish
community the media gives Sweden a
second look and Hillary Clinton endorses
Joe Biden i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show today's Ben Shapiro
show is sponsored by Express VPN your
online activity should not be public
protect yourself expressvpn comm / Ben
well welcome to our 1000th episode the
only thing that's special about this
episode is that I just said it's our
1000th episode that is the only thing
that we actually think is important
about that like it's all the same I was
gonna take the day off or 1000 episode
but I was told that that would be a bad
idea so let's jump right into the news
oh there is a weird phenomenon out there
or some people seem to be celebrating
the failures of the United States with
regard to coronavirus championing the
idea that the United States has been a
gigantic failure among these people is
Rachel Maddow who is seeking to blame
the entire pandemic on President Trump
which is weird because it seems like the
pandemic is it you know like everywhere
in fact the United States when it comes
to our death per million population is
basically middle-of-the-pack the United
States ranks about 179 tests per million
population according to World ometer
'he's by contrast spain is at 519 per
million italy is at 453 per million
France at 362 per million the UK is at
319 per million in other words the
United States ranks right now about half
of all of those other places on earth
nonetheless Rachel Maddow is out there
almost celebrating the idea that the
United States is number one why because
this allows her to dunk on President
Trump because Trump says America first
and now we are number one in the number
of coronavirus cases diagnosed a couple
things about that one we are also number
one in the number of tests we've
actually done in the United States in
terms of raw absolute numbers we are
number one in the number of tests so
what's very odd is you hear some people
in the media suggest we're under testing
we're really really under testing and
then they'll say but we're number one in
cases okay we're number one in cases in
the aggregate not per million population
right we're number one in cases just as
a as a Ross um when then when it comes
to testing we're also number one in
testing in Ross um but the media use two
different standards they'll say that on
a per capita basis the United States is
not number one when it comes to testing
but then they won't use per capita basis
when they talk about the number of cases
in the United States then we'll do that
the number of
in the United States the reality of the
situation is that the United States is
not close to number one in terms of the
number of deaths we have suffered from
coronavirus the United States has
actually handled this thing pretty well
except from New York I'm going to talk
about New York in just a few minutes
here but here is Rachel Maddow last
night trying to suggest that the United
States has engaged in widespread failure
why because on the back of failure you
can change the politics of the United
States and this phenomenon is really
ugly and really terrible this is the
phenomenon where folks on the Left try
to gin up a feeling of true disaster
not that the pandemic is not a disaster
a feeling that the government response
was a true thoroughgoing disaster simply
so the dickens and then suggest a vast
change to the system here's Rachel
Maddow doing just that last night
downplaying the threat ignoring the
experts refusing to prepare Donald Trump
is failing America the way that started
the way the clip came in you actually
missed the first little bit of it which
started with Donald Trump said he would
put America first and now he has the
United States leads the world in
coronavirus cases that all America first
slogan not aging well obviously in this
time can't hold back the smile there can
you Rachel then America first thing is
first of all again America is not the
worst place in the world for coronavirus
statistically speaking the United States
again not close to the worst place in
the world for coronavirus in fact the
United States ranks better in terms of
deaths per million population which is
the stat that you should be using the
United States ranks better than
virtually every European country with
the exception of Germany and when we
talk about how the United States is
doing and we just passed 1 million total
diagnosis of coronavirus and again that
is a vast undercounting of the number of
people who actually have coronavirus who
maybe 5 to 10 times that number
considering that huge number of people
are asymptomatic and antibody tests are
showing a multiple a multiple of that
number in terms of people who actually
have acquired kovat 19 and who have not
died if you're if you're looking at the
fact that we have a million cases and we
have a population of 330 million you'd
have to actually aggregate the number of
total cases in in Europe right which has
a similar population the EU altogether
has a population that looks a lot more
like the United States than any single
country in Europe so suggesting that the
United States has more raw cases than
for example Italy when Italy has
approximately at this point 200 and 1000
most cases but only 60 million members
of the population we have 330 million
people here in the United States so
again these numbers make no sense if you
if you look at how the United States has
performed with the exception of New York
which again we're gonna get to in a
second the United States has performed
exceptionally well exceptionally well
they were performing around where Canada
or Germany are outside of New York and
New York's been a disaster area and let
me give you those stats on New York so
that you understand that basically the
United States when it comes to the
treatment of copán 19 is two countries
New York and everywhere else when it
comes to New York New York is a
population about 19 million people in
New York State they've had about 23,000
deaths to date right now New York State
has one thousand one hundred and eighty
deaths per million population in New
York State Italy which was the hardest
hit country for a while now in Spain the
hardest hit country in Europe was Italy
at 27,000 deaths slightly slightly more
deaths than New York State but they've
three times the population at sixty
million so they only have 453 deaths per
million in Italy as opposed to 1180
deaths per million in New York State in
Spain which has been devastated they
have 519 deaths per million New York
State doubles that at 1180 if you take
New York State out of the calculation
which again because it is so outside the
the sort of normal distribution you can
make an argument for if you were to do
that the rest of the United States looks
like Germany or Canada so the idea that
this is equally devastated every part of
the United States is obviously untrue a
national policy would be a disaster
second of all this does raise some
questions about the governance in New
York where it supposedly Andrew Cuomo
was hero of the day I remember when the
media did the same thing after Hurricane
Katrina declaring that I believe his
Kathleen Blanco is the governor of
Louisiana at the time was suddenly a
wonderful governor and Mayor Ray Nagin
who's a horrible mayor of New Orleans by
calling his city a chocolate city that
had been taken revenge upon by the
federal government when he was telling
people not to leave the city in the
middle of the of the hurricane and the
media made him out to be a hero because
Bush had to be the bad guy
it's media malpractice what has gone on
in terms of how Trump has been treated
in the Trump administration have been
treated versus how the New York state
government has been treated and the New
York local government has been treated
it is absolute journalistic malpractice
if they're a Republican governor of New
York the the whining would never stop
the the the anger and rage would never
stop the media are angry at
Brian Kemp for telling people they can
reopen their barber shops then they are
at Andrew Cuomo in New York who didn't
shut down the state until late March and
Bill DeBlasio who's going out in public
and telling people that they could go
about their business through mid-march
it's absolutely incredible we'll get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that Mother's Day is
approaching it's kind of hard to see mom
right now
but mom should be able to see you and I
don't mean just like how you are now I
mean mom should be able to look at all
of the old memories she should be able
to take all that stuff that's in the
garage that is just moldering out there
all those old family films and she
should be able to view them and enjoy
them it really is important at this time
to forge stronger family connections
legacy box helps you do this legacy box
is a super simple mail and service tab
all your home movies and pictures
digitally preserved on a thumb drive DVD
or the cloud I can't think of anything
more moving as a parent I'm parent now
and also a child I can't think of
anything more moving than my parents
being able to look and all of our old
home videos that they haven't seen in
years and it really is an amazing thing
and I can't wait for my kids to do the
same thing for me but Oh your old films
are probably on those old film reels
that you can't actually view legacy box
makes it super simple Mother's Day is
fast approaching this is a great gift
the process is really easy you packet
and send your tapes their team digitizes
everything by hand you get that
perfectly preserved digital copies on a
thumb drive DVD or the cloud ready to
watch share and enjoy plus they keep you
up to date with regular email updates
throughout the digitizing process legacy
boxes the world's largest digitizer of
home movies and photos they've helped
over three-quarters of a million
families digitally preserve their past
for a limited time
legacy box is running a 50% off Mother's
Day special order your legacy box today
to take advantage of this amazing offer
it's one of the best discounts they've
ever offered that's a great discount
legacy box comm slash Ben for 50% off
while supplies last
really a meaningful and fantastic gift
so the United States has indeed
according to New York Times surpassed 1
million known corona virus cases the
Bleak milestone according to the New
York Times is yet another sign of how
the virus has upended life in America
taking lives destroying family spreading
through meat plants and nursing homes
prisons forcing businesses and schools
to close the true number of infections
is much higher than 1 million of course
roughly one out of every 130 people in
the US has now tested positive for the
virus now there's good news here and
there's bad news the good news is the
bad news is this thing spreads really
fast because we've been in lockdown and
still we have huge numbers probably 5 to
10 million people in the United States
have already gotten corona virus
the good news is that that means that we
are actually getting fairly close to
herd immunity in certain areas of New
York which is a good thing brand mean
that's what you're aiming for at a
certain point you're gonna have to aim
for hurting you hurting unity is
basically a vaccine right it is nature's
vaccine herd immunity is you reach the
level at which the reproduction rate of
a virus is less than one because so many
people have already had the virus and
for all the people right now who are
saying well there's no guarantee that
antibodies confirm unity if antibodies
don't confer immunity why are we
spending all of our time looking for a
vaccine that's exactly what a vaccine is
a vaccine just allows you to build up
your antibodies to a particular disease
so if you're putting all your faith in a
vaccine and at the same time shouting
from the rooftops that antibodies don't
confirm unity I don't know exactly what
you are waiting for at that point you
better just throw up your hands and go
out and enjoy your life right because
then you're talking about nothing is
going to stop this thing it is just a
matter of time before you get it and
then whatever happens to you happens to
you now in in worst news the u.s.
coronavirus death toll is far higher
than originally suggested according to
CDC data they're looking at excess
deaths over the prior five years versus
the vs. over this year versus B prior
five years state-to-state and they've
seen a significant uptick in New York
City obviously normally they see about
you know a thousand weekly deaths
something like that New York City they
were seeing up to six thousand weekly
deaths in New York City New York State
is something similar New Jersey you've
seen this huge spike Michigan you've
seen a spike that's now flattening off
Massachusetts there was some spike
Illinois has been a little bit softer in
terms of the the number of increased
deaths Marylyn has basically been kind
of on par actually and Colorado has been
nearly on par according to the New York
Times if you look at the provisional
deaths from all causes death counts in
New York New Jersey Michigan
Massachusetts Illinois Maryland and
Colorado have spiked far above their
normal levels for the period in New York
City the home of the biggest outbreak
the number of deaths over this period is
more than three times the normal number
recent data suggest it could've reached
six times higher than normal and that
means that there would be a significant
undercount
on the number of deaths from March 8th
to April 11th the the gap could have
been up to 2,000 people in New York City
it could've been up to 3,000 people in
New Jersey the statewide had been
another 700 people in Illinois these
numbers aren't enough to change the
overall infection fatality rate of this
thing which is probably between 0.5 and
point 6
according to best available data which
means it is significantly deadlier than
the flu as we've been saying it's also
significantly more transmissible than
the flu it is not three point four or
four percent as the w-h-o was originally
suggesting now what does this mean
it means that it will continue to be out
there and will continue to kill people
unless there's a therapeutic that comes
about now we're expecting some news from
Gilead Sciences a little bit later today
about that REM disappear which is that
drug that they were purporting to put
out there there was some good news a
couple of weeks ago suggestions that had
been effective then there was a study
that was cancelled in China I was
suggesting it wasn't as effective we're
gonna find out whether there's a
therapeutic on the way which would be
great but one thing to keep in mind this
thing is still out there it is still
infectious and that is what it is right
that is what it is we're just gonna have
to deal with that because as we remove
the lockdown there will indeed be a
spike in cases that that is not a shock
that's the purpose of the lockdown I
thought people who are surprised that
there's a spike in cases after the
lockdown I honestly don't know what they
were thinking I've been saying for weeks
that all the models were flawed because
they didn't expect a second wave well if
a lockdown is designed to prevent us
from going out and infecting each other
and then the lockdown ends because the
original lockdown was designed not only
to prevents us from infecting each other
but to stop us from infecting each other
for a specific purpose namely to not
swamp the healthcare system when we
relieve the lockdown people will be in
more contact with one another and then
there will be a spike in cases the
question isn't whether there's a spike
in cases without a vaccine of course
there will be and again the good news is
the more people get it the better the
chances that we eventually reach hurt
immunity that's what Sweden has been
thinking the bad news is the more people
get it the more people who would lie the
question is really what is the
alternative
and I've not heard any alternative from
people right maybe you're waiting for
the vaccine you don't know when that's
coming 12 to 18 months nobody's staying
home for 12 to 18 months maybe you're
waiting for a therapeutic maybe the
therapeutic will come maybe it won't you
don't know all we can do is be cautious
try and spread this out over time which
is why social distancing and masks
matter and all of the rest of us but the
notion that we are going to avoid an
increase in the number of cases like
everyone knows there's gonna be an
increase in the number of cases that's
why I'm constantly shocked by the way
people treat this thing online what oh
my god Georgia is opening up and they
have a spike in cases yeah no bleep
Sherlock I mean it's the purpose of the
lockdown is to stop that but the
lockdown can't last forever and it
served its actual purpose which was to
stop the overwhelming of the health care
system well talk about Florida in just a
second because people
using this as an excuse it up a
expectation that cannot be met by
reality that when people go out again
you're gonna be somehow safer than you
were when you went back in not much I
mean only because of the masks in the
social distancing but virus didn't
magically disappear we'll get to that in
just one second first let's talk about
the fact that if you're online right now
they're bad actors online - I mean this
is like heaven for hackers because
everybody's spending all their time
online retail shopping has all gone
online everybody is shopping online that
means a lot of credit card information
floating around
it means tons of your personal data
floating around hackers love this kind
of stuff you need a VPN expressvpn is
the best VPN I never go online without
using expressvpn Express we can make
sure your ISP can't see what sites you
visit instead your internet connection
is rerouted through Express VPNs at
secure servers each Express VPN server
has an IP address that shared among
thousands of users that means everything
you do is anonymized and can't be traced
back to you expressvpn also encrypts
100% of your data with best-in-class
encryption so your information is always
protected expressvpn is the fastest most
trusted VPN on the market it is rated
number 1 by C net wired the verge and
countless more so protect your online
activity today with the VPN I trust to
secure my privacy won't slow down your
computer really easy to install visit my
special link and express it VPN com so I
spending an extra 3 months for free on a
one-year package that's exp ress VPN com
/ban expressvpn comm / Ben to learn more
ok so New York is already planning for
all of this as they should
Florida is seeing a spike in cases
according to the New York Times to the
Miami Herald rather Florida's Department
of Health on Tuesday confirm 708
additional cases of Kovan 19 bringing
the state's total of confirmed cases to
32,000 846 there were 83 new deaths
announced the highest reported on a
single day that brought the statewide
total to just over a thousand yeah well
that's not great but that is not nearly
the original forecast there's gonna be
four or five thousand dead in Florida
okay so why are there gonna be
additional infections of course there
are also you shouldn't really look at
the death numbers because the death
numbers lag and when you look at the
death numbers you're looking at
infections from two weeks ago that's
when people are dying after lingering
unfortunately for a week or two in the
hospital tuesday's a number of new cases
in florida as the highest the state has
seen in the past three days
saturday was the lowest when the state
reported a total of three hundred and
six new cases and nine deaths which was
a steep decline of new daily cases and
death
not seen since late March that was
likely caused by the Florida Department
of Health changing its system of
providing updates so that was not
actually a change in the underlying data
it's just they changed how they were
providing the updates but people are
using this as an excuse to be like well
if we if we end the lockdown everything
is gonna go hog-wild its gonna go
haywire out here if you end the lockdown
people will be in contact with one
another there will be more infections
none of this was ever in doubt none of
this was ever in doubt and that's not
change the calculation here New York has
apparently set up a circuit breaker
Andrew Cuomo says that if either the
hospital system in an area of the state
had 70 percent of capacity or if the
rate of transmission reaches one point
one meaning for every person who has the
virus another one point one are infected
then that would constitute eight what he
called the circuit breaker the statewide
transmission rate is about 0.8% meaning
less than one person is infected he said
we want to do it without infecting more
people or overwhelming the hospital
system well that first one is not going
to happen overwhelming the hospital
system that's the one you can stop more
people will be infected it will continue
to run through the population that's
what viruses do social distancing will
help to lower that but that's just the
way things are gonna go the only thing
you can really control is whether people
are going to overwhelm the hospital
system that's where the circuit breaker
should exist dr. Debra Brooks yesterday
at the White House she said listen we
understand there's gonna be increased
infections and we are ready for a second
way the second way it should occur our
job right now and our job in the White
House to ensure that we are ready for
anything that happens in the fall
whether it's testing whether it's PPE
whether it's ventilators whether it's a
complete surveillance system that
understands that we have to track for
asymptomatic s' as well as symptomatic
individuals all of those pieces need to
accelerate and expand to be ready for
the fall okay so she's getting ready for
fall doctor foul she also says that
everyone who needs a test will be able
to get one by late May or June and the
testing doesn't really change the
outcome here because once you're tested
the treatment is exactly the same
whether you were tested or not if you go
to the hospital and you're having
trouble and you're having trouble
breathing you will get a test and then
you will get treatment even if you test
positive for kovat 19:00 that's probably
not going to change anything except
you're gonna stay home but we've already
told people if you have a cough and you
have a fever you're supposed to be
staying home anyway so the tests
actually don't change all that much
other than if you have some sort of
contact tracing that can be put in place
to tell people around you that they need
to stay home even if
asymptomatic now that could help again
prevent the the fast spread and
overwhelming the health care system but
I keep reiterating the same point people
are gonna get it people gonna die that's
how this works
Sweden has taken this into account
Sweden will not see a second wave
because they didn't do the lockdown in
the first place
Sweden which it's amazing to watch right
the New York Times swindled on a dime
they're two separate articles in the New
York Times today talking about how maybe
Sweden did this right after weeks of
suggesting that Sweden was a disaster
area there's an article in The New York
Times today talking about how Sweden may
have done this right because there won't
be a second wave apparently people are
going out they are they're enjoying life
there are restaurants that are open if
they don't social distance then they're
shut down for the day but people are not
actually being prosecuted gathering some
more than 50 people are banned museums
have closed sporting events have been
cancelled at the end of March the
authorities banned visits to nursing
homes and that's pretty much it
according to the New York Times there
are almost no fines police officers can
only ask people to oblige pedestrians
wearing masks are generally stared at as
if they've just landed from Mars so they
are going to be okay I mean Sweden looks
like they're gonna be okay because
nothing's gonna change there because
nothing changed there in the first place
in terms of people locking down
permanently where you are gonna see the
spikes and where people lock down
permanently and we artificially suppress
the numbers and now the numbers are
gonna spike again maybe the artificial
suppression was necessary so we didn't
overwhelm the system that's possible but
we've been saying for weeks we were all
going to become Sweden it was just a
matter of time as to when we did that
and so everybody who's ripping on Sweden
I have a question what was your
alternative that we're gonna be locked
down forever I mean now I want to turn
to New York City because as I've said
the the media coverage of New York is
just egregiously bad egregiously bad
look at the numbers look at the numbers
once more the state's death rates in New
York City deaths per million population
in New York State 1 million 180 deaths
per million 100 180 deaths at 1 1180
deaths per million that is twice the
rate of Spain that is more than twice
the rate of Italy so New York did
something wrong here now some of that is
population density some of that is
dramatic government mismanagement and it
is amazing to watch as the as the media
blamed President Trump in the federal
government for the state completely
botching it Andrew Cuomo was hero of the
Republic for at least a month here why
because he was going on TV and shouting
President Trump about how he needed more
ventilators but Andrew Cuomo was able to
completely abdicate responsibility for
his own state and by the way we
shouldn't be treating every governor
equivalently Kristi Noem in South Dakota
the governor of South Dakota
she never shut down her state she
basically her citizens through a parade
yesterday because she didn't shut down
the state because she shouldn't have
shut down the state Texas never
completely shut down
Florida never completely shut down did
they get it worse than DeBlasio and
Cuomo did in New York of course not but
if you look at the media coverage Cuomo
and de Blasio are the gold standard for
how you're supposed to act during a
pandemic and DeSantis in Florida and
Abbott in Texas and Kristi Noem in in
South Dakota and in the governor of
Alaska and all these guys are bad people
they're bad people because they opened
up and then the media have a rooting
interest and it seems that that rooting
interest definitely aligns with D versus
R because of the perfect proof of this
by the way is Jared policy in Colorado
is starting to open up he's not getting
anywhere near the kind of flack that
other governors who have an R next to
their name are getting we're gonna get
to New York in just a second because by
the way the the deaths per million in
New York State is really high the deaths
in New York City per million are
astonishing right the deaths per million
in New York City are absolutely crazy
there there been about how many how many
does have there been in New York City
proper from Kogan 19 I believe there
have been about 12,000 deaths in New
York City to date from kovat 19 yeah
Tibet 12,500 12,500 and there's an about
8.4 million so we'll round that up for
for purposes of being nice to New York
that means that there have been 12 let's
see 12,000 mmm it means that there have
been approximately I'm trying to do the
math here 7,200 cases per million in New
York is that could that possibly be
right maybe I mean it's it's about twice
the rate of New York State right because
that means that because it's so heavily
located they've had 12,000 cases so
about half the number of deaths and it's
about its Nighy its high let's put it
this way it's very it's much higher than
the New York it can't be 7,200 I'm doing
an a throng here but the bottom line is
that you are looking at a death per
million rate that is extraordinarily
high other hereness it's about about
1388 30
190 deaths per million in New York City
so in other words almost three times the
rate that you saw in Italy almost three
times and yet New York State's
government has been treated with kid
gloves know they're doing everything
right they're doing pretty much
everything wrong and I'll give you an
example of how the media really treats
the mayor and the governor with kid
gloves because their activities over the
last 24 hours
on a political level would kill any
Republican who attempted this kind of
stuff and should by the way we'll get to
that in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that right now is
probably not the time you want to be
going out to the auto parts store II
don't wanna be standing in line and then
even if you could the auto parts store
is probably overcharging you they're
giving you a generic part that doesn't
actually fit your car instead you should
be checking out Rock Auto calm
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
possible prices rather than changing
prices based on what the markets will
bear like the airline's do why would you
spend up to twice as much for the same
parts you will really get the
rock-bottom prices at rockauto.com chain
stores have different price tiers for
professional mechanics and
do-it-yourselfers Rock Auto dot-coms
prices are the same for everybody
they'll reliably low rockauto.com always
offers the lowest prices possible rather
than changing prices based on what the
market will bear like the airline's do
rockauto.com is for everybody it doesn't
require membership or account login best
of all the prices of Rock Lauder
anti-crime as I've said they are the
best in the business amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need rockauto.com there
could not be a worse time to go to an
auto parts store than right now in human
history so go right go right now to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck and
right Shapiro's in there how did you
hear about us box so they know that we
say that helps us and it also helps them
go check out Rock auto comm and get your
car part for the best available price
okay so let's talk about New York now
because somehow the governor of New York
was able to escape responsibility for
the fact that his state has been a
complete bleep show since the very
beginning he was calling for thirty
forty thousand ventilators didn't end up
needing one third that when Trump said
that he didn't think that's what the
numbers would end up being whose ripped
up and down how dare he say that how did
because it was pretty obvious that they
weren't actually gonna need those kind
of numbers again and you want to say the
Cuomo was bargaining with Trump for the
ventilators guess what who's bargaining
instead they're states with medical
aiders Andrew Cuomo didn't shut down the
state until late March probably talk
about Trump was late on the game Trump
issued his his 15 days to slow the
spread I believe was March March 15th
March 16th
Cuomo didn't shut down the state until
March 23rd mayor de Blasio was going
around in early March telling people
that should go out and celebrate their
lives in New York and everything was
hunky-dory somehow these public
officials escaped escaped the the center
of the media why well because the
Democratic agenda here is to blame it
all on the federal government just like
Hurricane Katrina where it's up to the
state of New Orleans to control the
safety of the citizens of the state of
New Orleans and I say this as a resident
of California
I think Gavin Newsom is a garbage
governor I think he's going too far
right now in a lot of the shutdown
orders I think that a lot of what he's
saying is insane
but guess what didn't happen in
California what happened in New York now
part of that has to do with population
density but you know where there's
pretty heavy population density is San
Francisco you know where else there's
pretty heavy population density Seattle
you know what didn't see New York either
of those cities anyway Nancy Pelosi has
been basically you know issuing the
challenge to the Trump administration
suggesting that they blew it it's all
about the Trump administration blowing
it not about New York which again remove
New York from the National Statistics
and the rest of the United States
looks like Germany which is supposedly
the model of how you stamp this thing
down here is Nancy Pelosi blaming Trump
what did the president know and when did
he know it in addition to which what the
scientists tell him and when did he tell
them because action as a matter of fact
this president has presided over the
worst disaster in our country's history
an assault on the lives and the
livelihood of likelihoods of the
American people and he did so by neglect
of information also denial and delay in
accepting the facts oh ok so Nancy I
remember in early March when you
proposed a grand total of 8 billion
dollars for funding for for the pandemic
that was like March 6 hey I remember now
don't you remember Nancy Pelosi at the
top of her lungs hollering for national
shut down no I don't either because that
didn't happen she waited she was on the
same timeline as President Trump and by
the way she's the species a Speaker of
the House she's getting the same
information the Trump was getting this
idea that Trump was getting some sort of
information that was unavailable to
Nancy Pelosi is just it's fantasy
there's there's there's no case and
there is no reality in which that is the
truth in late February she was going to
Chinatown in San Francisco and telling
people to come on out to Chinatown okay
meanwhile what was going on in New York
in New York they were late on the game
Governor Cuomo is admitting as much
and the meteor like all look look at
that honesty from Governor Cuomo I'm
confused does that mean that he did a
good job now here's Governor Cuomo
yesterday saying I didn't blow the bugle
on it watch as he fusses this right even
even here he fights it he says I wish
I'd been blowing the bugle on this in
December or January dude you weren't
blowing the bugle on this in February
you were not blowing the bugle on this
in the first week of March
don't give me January or December I mean
Trump could use that same excuse where
we get in February like everything that
people say about Trump and now Trump
didn't take this seriously enough he's
not the governor of the state it
actually had this outbreak he's the
President of the United States he didn't
handle this well at the very beginning
but you know who handled it a lot worse
the state think I actually got swamped
here here's Andrew Cuomo you know
basically lying by omission here saying
yeah I didn't blow the bugle in December
or January yeah you didn't do it in
February you didn't do it in early march
either here's Andrew Cuomo they wish
someone stood up and blew the bugle and
if no one was going to blow the bugle I
would feel much better if I was a bugle
blower last December in January even
though no one danced to the music I
would feel better sitting here today
saying I blew the bugle about Wuhan
province in January I can't say that
okay that's that's not only true you
didn't do it again for weeks afterward
New York was late on the game here and
then Cuomo was asked about you know the
fact that you were late on the game here
and kumo like governor's don't you
pandemics that's a national issue really
is it because it seems like you have
been credited with doing a wonderful job
at New York despite the fact that you
have not actually done a wonderful job
in New York it turns out that we have a
federalist system and then not every
state is similarly situated so it's
pretty convenient that you're able to
suggest that you are in control it's
local control when you want it to be
local control and national control when
it's national control remember I'm being
perfectly even-handed on this point when
Trump said this is up to the states and
then he said no I have national control
I'm the president I said no it's up to
the states you got to be consistent on
this well the same thing holds true for
Cuomo you don't get to do pandemics are
a national issue they're not my state's
issue when you can issue state shut down
orders and when you suggest to President
Trump get out of the state's business so
here's Andrew Cuomo trying to evade
responsibility governors don't do global
pandemics right
but there's a whole international
national health community would do that
we're all the experts where was the New
York Times where was the Wall Street
Journal where was all the bugle blowers
who should say be careful there's a
virus in China that maybe in the United
States that was November December we're
sitting here January February still
debating how serious this is okay this
is unbelievable
well Cuomo is saying here is nearly
word-for-word identical to the stuff
Trump says or Trump says that over and
over and the members the mayor like well
we wrote an editorial about this in
early February saying coronavirus was a
problem and don't remember Joe Biden
writing an editorial for USA Today in
late January okay so why is that when
Cuomo says it it's totally fine and the
meteor like oh great America's governor
and then when Trump says the exact same
thing it's that man town plays his own
responsibility for this
it's Cuomo's state that got hit and not
only that it's almost garbage policies
like hey look an elderly person came in
with kovin 19 let's send them back to
their nursing home that that really
exacerbated the problem it is Cuomo's
policy of treating his entire state as a
unitary body as opposed to hey wait a
second maybe upstate New York with a
population density that doesn't even
look like the population density of New
York City may not be exactly like New
York City it's incredible you want to
know the double standard that is held
for Andrew Cuomo versus anywhere else
check out what Andrew Cuomo had to say
about the homeless problem in New York
City now the homeless problem New York
City has been a problem for a long time
so no problem in LA - it's a problem in
Seattle it's problem in San Francisco
liberally governed areas have a serious
homeless problem not only because urban
areas tend to draw homeless folks but
also because these cities have refused
to crack down on the homeless largely at
the pass of Democrats who have suggested
it is a civil right to sleep on the
streets there's been a problem for a
very long time
only now our governor's like Andrew
Cuomo discovering that it's actually a
bad thing to let mentally ill people
sleep on the streets in their own filth
only now are they discovering this is a
bad thing but listen to the language
there Andrew Cuomo uses here because the
Andrew Cuomo uses language about the
homeless people sleeping on the subways
if any Republican use this language that
person would be out of a job here is
Andrew Cuomo today that is
disgusting what is happening on those
subway cars it's disrespectful to the
essential workers who need to ride the
subway system upstate New York need to
ride the buses to get to work they
deserve better and they will have better
we have to have a public transportation
system that is clean where the trains
are disinfected your homeless people on
trains it's not even safe for the
homeless people to be on trains
ok so I agree with him that it's
actually a bad situation for all most
people beyond trends in fact I believe
that it's a bad situation for homeless
people to be homeless meaning that you
should not be allowed to sleep on the
streets you know who used to agree with
me the mayor of New York Rudy Giuliani
right when when New York was not turning
back into a garbage heap under Bill
DeBlasio I said Michael Bloomberg
Michael Bloomberg agreed with that also
but to use the word disgusting in
conjunction here is there any doubt that
if a Republican had said this the
headline would have been Republican
governor homeless disgusting right well
is there any question that would have
been the coverage of course that would
been the coverage the person would have
had to apologise has Cuomo been asked
and the homeless problem is partially
his fault it's his state de Blasio has
been allowing the homelessness in New
York to build for years at a time
through garbage governance and then like
I'll guess what it's a problem that we
have a homeless problem in New York City
well no no bleep Sherlock
congratulations okay now it's not just
Andrew Cuomo whose botched this one
thoroughly and royally it is also Mayor
Bill de Blasio the worst mayor in
America I mean truly the worst mayor in
America and I live in a horrible mayor
Eric Garcetti is a horrible mayor and
the man is fencing off like the the
overpass is on Mulholland Drive
therefore feet square because what are
we gonna do we're gonna guess the other
have a rave out there or something but
mayor de Blasio is actually a horrible
person an actual likes Anthony stat
communist the the the man not only is a
hypocrite who is going to the YMCA in
the middle of the pandemic while
shutting down gyms and now apparently
Jets on over to Prospect Park in
Brooklyn because he likes walking over
there first like he actually takes the
city transport over there and then he
walks around over there and doesn't
socially distance according to the New
York Post not only that Bill de Blasio's
take on social distancing this is a man
who suggests that he stands against
anti-semitism in New York wait till you
see what Bill de Blasio had to say Oh
last 24 hours no other group would be
treated by Bill DeBlasio the way the
Jews in New York are being treated by
Bill DeBlasio it's incredible
I'll show you the example in just one
second first let us talk about a
fantastic fantastic Mother's Day gift
okay this is it really like you're not
gonna do better than this
Jewelry is obviously one of the most
popular gifts you can get from others
day there's a good reason for it you
can't really go wrong what's mom gonna
do be upset jewelry is unbelievable
stuff like I've been using it on the
ladies in my life for years that means
my wife or my mom I don't have a lady on
the side there is nothing more classic
and timeless and fine pearl jewelry
which doesn't need to break your budget
at the pearl source you get the highest
quality pearl jewelry and up to 70% off
retail price I mean this is beautiful
stuff I've got stuff from the Pearl
source have a necklace for my wife that
is just gorgeous earrings for my wife
that are amazing looking
pearl source cuts out the middleman they
eliminate traditional five times markup
by jewelry stores and they sell directly
to you the consumer by the way your
local jewelry store is closed it is not
a quote unquote essential business that
means you're gonna have to shop online
anyway so save all sorts of money when
you head on over to the pearl source
Mother's Day is next Sunday don't wait
the Pearl source offers fast and free
two-day shipping on every order with
zero contact delivery everything comes
beautifully packaged in an elegant
jewelry box so it is ready to be given
as a gift and if you're not sure if
she'll love the gift no worries the
Pearl source comes with a no hassle
60-day money-back guarantee so it's
risk-free which is a great deal
especially considering the fact that
sometimes you buy jewelry and runs like
I like that other one better so go check
out the Pearl source right now don't
overpay for jewelry head on over to the
Pearl source I trust the folks who run
it I've known them a long time they're
really solid honest people I can't
testify to their character we're highly
than that my children play with their
children like that not during the
pandemic but all other times for a
limited time listeners to my show can
take 20% off your entire order for
Mother's Day so the prices are already
70% off and now you can take 20% off
your entire order for Mother's Day go to
the Pearl source calm /ban enter promo
code been and check out for 20% off your
entire order 70% lower than traditional
retail prices in you get 20% off if you
want find pearl jewelry at the best
prices online go straight to the source
the Pearl source that's the Pearl source
calm backslash been enter promo code
been at checkout for that 20% off
Mother's Day discount and it will arrive
in time for Mother's Day because of that
fast and free two-day shipping already
so we're gonna get to Bill DeBlasio the
worst mayor in America Bar None without
a doubt
well guess
that in just one second and again he
continues to escape the media scrutiny
it's pretty unbelievable
we'll get to that in just a moment first
being locked inside right now what could
make you happy well what's something
that could give you at least a glimmer
of pleasure in this dark and depressing
time how about a second leftist here's
tumblr
they've been reproducing like rabbits
around here and you get two of them when
you become a daily wire insider plus
were all-access member I am not fitting
to you tell you our members get many
amazing benefits including of course the
magnificent irreplaceable singular
leftist yours tumbler you also get an
ad-free website experience access to all
of our live broadcasts and show library
the full three hours of the ben shapiro
show access to the mailbag and now you
get exclusive election inside op-eds
from me daily where members also get to
ask us questions during backstage you
also get to participate in all access
live our brand-new interactive
programming feature now this is content
for our all-access members it's been
temporarily opened up that ends this
week so now is a great time to become an
all-access member i'm doing another one
this week a little bit later this week
last night we had a lot of fun it's the
time i wear t-shirts check it out a p.m.
Eastern 5 p.m. Pacific the deal is going
away soon
hurry become an insider plus or
all-access member double your tears with
two leftist tears tumblers go to daily
wire calm slash subscribe to get started
in get 10% off with coupon code Shapiro
that is daily wire calm / subscribe
coupon code Shapiro get the rarest of
all beverage vessels times two okay so
just in time well in a second we are
going to get to Bill de Blasio first I
just have to say that the Stinger here
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so just in time for Israeli Independence
Day bill de blasio has decided his son
to call out the Jew so here's what's
been going on in Williamsburg which is a
very what they call blackhat community
it's it's a Hasidic community so it's
even sort of a different version than
blackhat they're a bunch of different
striations even inside the Orthodox
Jewish community I of course remember it
is clear the vast majority of the
orthodox community around the united
states has shut down my shul shot down
before lockdown orders in california
this has been true for every major show
in the los angeles area it's also true
of every major shul in the new york area
there's one particular area of new york
in Williamsburg where there's Hasidic
groups and they've still been gathering
and this is bad I've mentioned this on
the show I've said that there are some
groups most huh sit-in by the way are
shutting down like even among custom it
is it normal to shut down most Hasidic
groups are shutting down now there are
some groups who have still been getting
together this is bad this is bad across
the board I've said that Christian
groups shouldn't do it Jewish groups
shouldn't do it no groups should be
doing this right no group events right
now I have relatives who are in-laws who
are gonna be doing a wedding in a few
months and they're gonna socially limit
the wedding I mean this is just the way
things work now there was a funeral for
a rabbi over in over in Williamsburg
yesterday and a bunch of people got
together on the street now there are
parts of the crowd that were socially
distanced I know that I have a lot of
listeners in this community there were
certain parts of the crowd that were in
fact socially distance and staying away
from each other there are other parts of
the crowd that look like them or not
right there are a lot of people who
showed up at this funeral which was
outdoors there no cars on the street
it's not good
yeah supposed to be doing this there
were members of the Orthodox community
by the way who were going around and
telling people they needed to socially
distance or get off the street so all
this led Bill DeBlasio who's a terrible
person to tweet this out he tweeted out
yesterday my message to the Jewish
community and all communities is this
simple the time for warnings has passed
I have instructed the NYPD to proceed
immediately to summons or even arrest
those who gather in large groups this is
about stopping this disease and saving
lives period and so a couple of things
DeBlasio personally traveled to over
there in order to tell people to
disperse because if it comes from Bill
de Blasio's mouth it's taking much more
seriously than then if the NYPD shows up
no one was arrested by the way when they
were told to disperse everybody did to
spur
second of all bill de blasio likes
showing up personally what's he gonna do
get out on top of there and with his
bullhorn everyone please leave everyone
please by the way this is the part of
the rally that you're not being shown
right this is this comes courtesy of a
member of the considered community in
Williamsburg one of the problems of
photography is that if you use a
particular type of lens it makes people
look closer together you can see here
that there was a fair amount of social
distancing even in Williamsburg but with
that said obviously you don't want big
crowds of any type doing this sort of
thing but de Blasio singled out the
Jewish community and he didn't just say
like this little kinetic subsection of
Williamsburg
he said the Jewish community more
broadly as though like all the Jews on
Broadway were getting together in their
off hours and gathering in large groups
again these are pictures from this
funeral you can see people socially
distancing and wearing masks at parts of
this rally so this is not to say that
there are pictures of people were really
close together and that's really bad but
a lot of people were not particularly
close together and that wasn't all that
bad the point here is that de Blasio
only singled out the Jewish community is
the Jewish community the only group of
people in New York who have been getting
together in large groups
well what's let's take this one to the
to the evidence yesterday the Blue
Angels did a flyover in New York City
here are some pictures from the Blue
Angels fly over in New York City you can
see are those rather large crowds they
are rather large crowds are they outside
just like the Williamsburg gathering yes
they are our people pretty close
together absolutely and this has been
happening for a while there was all
sorts of video and pictures from the
USNS comfort arriving in New York City
just a couple of weeks ago and you
remember there are big crowds out there
not socially distancing watching the
USNS comfort come into the harbor did
Bill de Blasio call out those people did
he arrive with his bullhorn and his
giant monster body to tell people that
they needed to disperse while strangling
the groundhog he did not right he
singled out the Jewish community and
then he has the gall to suggest well you
know new anti-semitism in New York is
never a thing no no we won't tolerate
anti-semitism in New York
what a fool he is what a fool he is and
let me point out that that failure to
abide by social distancing standards has
no specific race and no specific
religion because it is not tied to race
or religion
I'll also note that that bill de blasio
is fostering a program to give out free
Ramadan meals something like 500 Ramadan
meals at 30 sites that's that's fine I
mean okay but he's facilitating that at
30 sites I would imagine that that's
gonna be kind of tough and
social distancing putting all of that
aside can you imagine if bill de blasio
said you know we have higher rates of
transmission in the black community so
I'm telling the black community right
now in New York City if you don't stop
social if you don't stop gathering in
large crowds we're gonna send the NYPD
to a rescue we bill de blasio ever say
that about black folks in New York City
of course not because it's absurd in
Chicago by the way this is a serious
problem people are getting together in
very large groups and it ain't positive
right here there were two separate
thousand person parties in New York in
Chicago indoors one of them involving
strippers TMZ reported on it did Lori
Lightfoot the mayor of Chicago say no to
the black community
stop getting together because otherwise
we'll arrest you so this let's look like
social distancing to you by the way I
mean these are large groups of people in
small areas partying it up in the middle
of a pandemic writes the mask of the Red
Death kind of stuff from from Edgar
Allan Poe right everybody just getting
together and there's a there's there's
another party with strippers going on
all sorts of good times over in Chicago
now is that specific to the so-called
black community no people are idiots
people do idiotic things okay most
people are not idiots thank God most
people are not doing idiotic things but
to single out the Jewish community again
would any mayor in the United States
ever single out the black community for
social gatherings like this one the
answer of course is no but Bill DeBlasio
is perfectly willing to single out the
Jewish community because Bill DeBlasio
can get away with it he understands that
the folks in Williamsburg Encana vote
for him anyway so that what what a
wonderful mayor he is what just
incredible incredible leadership we've
seen from New York but this is all
Trump's fault in the end right and in
the end we can blame all of this on
Trump because Trump says dumb things at
press conferences doesn't matter that
the Trump team basically does the right
thing in terms of action the real
question is that the Trump team is
they're just bad and we know they're bad
because they're orange and very bad in
Orange Jim Acosta by the way over at CNN
and you know I'm about to say ladies
find you somebody who loves you like Jim
Acosta wants Jim Acosta Jim Acosta
yesterday at the White House asked
President Trump about how did we get
from your projection of zero to 1
million why is it that no one at CNN
well grill Andrew Cuomo or Bill de
Blasio but we're gonna get the same
question in every press conference why
were you so wrong in early March how
about ask him like what he's doing right
now you know he's not doing right now
condemning specific
racial / religious groups for not
socially distancing and suggesting the
cops are gonna come pick them up other
things he is not doing he is also not
sending nursing home patients with kovat
19 back to their nursing homes other
things he is not doing treating the
entirety of the United States as one
inseparable bloc in terms of policy
other things he's not doing under
supplying the the people who are asking
him for things but the only questions
that come from the media about how Trump
is a very bad orange man who's very bad
in orange again here's the costume
costume today the u.s. hit a grim
milestone of 1 million cases of the
corona virus back in late February you
predicted that the number of cases would
go down to zero how did we get from your
prediction of 0 to 1 million well it
will go down to 0 ultimately and you
have to understand when it comes to
cases we do much more testing than
anybody else so we could go to some of
these other countries you know as an
example China if you test you're gonna
show many more cases and so this is you
know obviously the media attempting to
to play this game they did it yesterday
also with regard to Mike Pence so Mike
Pence went to the Mayo Clinic and he
didn't wear a mask at the Mayo Clinic
and everybody else is wearing a mask at
the Mayo Clinic and the associated press
reported Vice President Mike Pence chose
not to wear him face mask Tuesday during
a tour of the Mayo Clinic in Rochester
Minnesota an apparent violation of the
world-renowned Medical Center's policy
requiring them video feeds show that
pence didn't wear a mask when he met
with a male employee who has recovered
from Koba 19 and is now donating plasma
he was also maskless when he visited a
lab where Mayo conducts corona virus
test who's the only participant not to
wear a mask during a roundtable
discussion all the other participants
did including the FDA chief Stephen Hahn
taught Mayo officials governor Tim Walz
and US Representative Jim Hagedorn this
all over in Minnesota
first of all quick note you know one of
the costs that people have not been
talking about is the Mayo Clinic which
is one of the finest medical
institutions on planet earth had to cut
tens of thousands of jobs apparently
because people are not being allowed to
do quote-unquote elective surgeries
which in many cases are not supremely
elective simply because of Kovan 19 now
people are very very angry at pence for
not wearing the mask
why did Penn say that he didn't wear the
mask he says his Vice President of the
United States and tested for corona
virus on a regular basis everyone around
me is tested for corona virus since I
don't have it I thought it'd be a good
opportunity for me to be here to be able
speak to researchers he's incredible
healthcare personnel look them in the
eye and say thank you now the real
reason that he's not wearing the mask is
of course because he wants a picture of
himself at the Mayo Clinic right I mean
this is how politicians treat the media
Nancy Pelosi is on the floor of the
house wiping her nose and putting it on
the podium I mean really there's video
of her doing that so why is everybody
angry at pens because he didn't about
this this is real turning here because
they're there because he didn't abide by
the social research he's being tested
every single day I promise you for
coronavirus they're taking a nasal swab
of that dude every five minutes is he
actually a danger to the people at the
Mayo Clinic
he's like the least dangerous person in
America to be at the Mayo Clinic
maskless but we're gonna create a faux
outrage over all of this and this is the
goal of so many in the media asking
these questions they're just asking dumb
questions here this happened yesterday -
there's a reporter who suggested that
the United States is still under testing
this is not true the United States is
not under testing he went out he went
after Trump and said you know President
Trump you keep saying that we have the
most tests in the world that's very very
bad and then dr. Bert's jumps in and
basically smashed him down and then
Trump doubles down on it South Korea's
testing was 11 per per a hundred
thousand and we're at 17 okay well one
of the things I love most about that is
that Burks is like the A student in the
class and Trump is just a D student and
you sitting the base like yeah who how
about you Yahoo you know I think yeah
whoo it's pretty spectacular stuff but
every question from the media to the
Trump administration is geared at what
are what what are about your gaffes
what about your failures if Obama were
president there'd be none of this not a
single iota of this all you have to do
is check out the questions that are
generally asked you Andrew Cuomo in New
York that's all you really have to do
okay now let's get some things I like
and then a bevy of things that I hate so
things that I like today so today is in
fact Yamahas moot it Israeli
Independence Day that is a very good
thing for the world because the only
democracy in the Middle East is the
Jewish state and by the way it's one of
the greats
stories in world history the Jews a
people who have been persecuted for
several thousand years regaining their
historic homeland in the middle of the
20th century after the destruction of
European Jewry at the rate of 6 million
people nearly half of world Jewry
murdered in forests and shot down gas
chambers and concentration camps and the
State of Israel is an amazing amazing
place it really is if you never visited
when all this is over you should go
visit Israel it's incredible it's an
incredible place Colton who's my
producer came with me to Israel when we
went last year and it doesn't matter
whether you're Christian or whether
you're Jewish whether you're Muslim
Israel is an unbelievable place it is an
incredible incredible place all the
people who haters will don't know a damn
thing about it
all the people who suggest that it's
very bad for there to be a Jewish state
there are lots of Christian states in
Europe the fact that there is one state
that is reserved for the Jewish religion
as the official religion of the state of
Israel that is a very good thing
considering the long history of
persecution of the Jews is very
interesting how for 2,000 years there
was no Jewish state and Jews were
persecuted now there's a Jewish state
and people like you know the reason that
people hate Jews is because of that
Jewish state say oh well it seems like
you sort of shifted the rationale there
on us real quick the fact that Israel
exists is the protection for Jews
because I'll get you know who I will not
rely upon for the protection of the Jews
people like Bill DeBlasio people like
Jeremy Corbyn people like Bernie Sanders
I'm not gonna rely on their protection
the fact that Israel exists is the last
line of defense for Jews on a religious
basis because in Europe s where Jews are
fleeing as the anti-semitism arises if
America stays America America is the
greatest country in the world for Jews
but as it stands you know if America
moves in another direction the final
hope for the safety of Jews will always
be in in a in a Jewish state that is
able to protect Jews all over the world
America is an amazing amazing place but
do I trust that officials like Bill
DeBlasio are interested in protecting
all of their citizens including Jews not
after tweets like the one he sent out
today so good good for Israel and that
that is their celebrating under bad
circumstances but if you ever have the
opportunity to go visit Israel you
certainly should it's an amazing
incredible place and a top American
allied America's real only ally in the
region
alrighty time for it some will actually
want one more quick thing I like so
apparently there are some new results
that are breaking from Gilead about rim
disappear this according to stat news
come gili had made the announcement in a
statement on Wednesday stating we
understand that the trial has met its
primary endpoint the company said that
the National Institute of Allergy and
Infectious Diseases will provide data at
an upcoming briefing the government runs
studies show that the medicine is
effective against kovat 19 so the this
this particular study is the most
important and rigorously designs has to
from disappear in kovat 19 the study
compared REMS to severe to placebo and
800 patients with neither patients or
our physicians knowing who got the drug
instead of the placebo so there
shouldn't be any unconscious bias he's
affecting the conclusions the main goal
of the study is the time until patients
improve with different measures of
improvement depending on how sick they
were to begin with Scott Gottlieb former
FDA commissioner said that this should
now be added to the emergency use
authorization for the toolbox he said
REMS this severe isn't a homerun but
looks active and can be part of a
toolbox of drugs and diagnostics that
substantially lower our risk heading
into the fall REM too severe which must
be given intravenously is likely to
remain a treatment for patients who are
hospitalized but it's also likely it
will be the most effective in patients
who have been infected more recently
rather than less Gilead on Wednesday did
release data from its own study of REM
dis severe in patients with severe koban
19 the study showed similar rates of
clinical improvement in patients treated
with a 5 day and 10-day course of REM to
severe so they said that it may be
possible to treat patients with a 5 day
treatment of REMS this if you're not the
10 day course that was originally used
data disclosed Thursday from 397
patients the study didn't reveal much
about how well it's working but the
conclusion is that there are basically
two durations of treatment there is some
level of efficacy so that is a that is
some good news hopefully we will see
some some new stats on all of this
patients in the trial generally lived 8
persitz 8 percent of patients treated
with five days of reminisce of your died
compared to 11 percent of the patients
treated for 10 days outside of Italy
where 77 patients were treated the
overall mortality rate across the entire
study was 7 percent which is lower than
those seen in other studies which have
been in the teens or 20s so hopefully
this will be a a in a drug added to the
toolbox of new therapeutics we will hope
coming out every day so that that is
that is definitely good news okay time
for some things that I hate
so let's look for a second to be at the
20/20 rays so Justin Amash the
libertarian from Michigan announced that
he is going to run for president on a
third-party ticket which means that his
immediate family and the remaining
quote-unquote nevertrump pers will
probably vote for him that's like seven
people he is not actually a threat to
win a severe number a significant number
of votes in this election the president
Trump has high approval ratings among
Republicans the Democrats are gonna be
able to get out there base I do not see
a lot of room for libertarian in this
election cycle of libertarians blue last
time around when there was widespread
dissatisfaction with both candidates I
don't think that he's going to have much
of a shot here and then I on policy I
tend to like Justin Amash I like many of
the things he has said but he does not
have a constituency at this point
outside of his congressional district
and so the idea this is gonna radically
change the race is very silly I also do
not like the idea on the right of third
party candidates in this particular
election the reason being it is going to
create a narrative that I think is
absolutely false
which is that if you do not vote for
Justin Amash it is because you embrace
every aspect of President Trump it's
because you love all of the bad things
about him and that obviously is not true
a lot of people just think that Justin
Amash ain't gonna be President and I'm
gonna vote for Trump against Biden right
that is the logic I would think of most
Republicans including most libertarians
who vote Republican is they're saying
why would I throw away my vote on a
Justin Amash when I could be voting in a
in a close fought election that really
is going to decide a lot about the
future of our country specifically
because the pandemic has shifted the
internal politics of the country fairly
dramatically so is Justin Amash has run
a bad idea I mean not for Justin Amash
you can do it he wants I mean it's a
free country is it something that is
that changes the race in any real way
the answer of course is really no
meanwhile it is fun to watch as the
Democrats simultaneously pursue two
avenues of 2020 strategy Avenue number
one is massive change on the back of a
global catastrophe and Avenue number two
is Joe Biden cannot be held to the same
standard we hold everybody else on me to
stuff and that that's really fun to
watch because on the one hand it really
undercuts Biden on two separate levels
on the one hand Biden likes to say that
he is basically the status quo candidate
the status quo ante cannon we're gonna
go
to the great days of Obama remember how
great it was when that great remember
how fantastic it was back in the days of
Obama well you can have that back if you
just vote for Joe Biden also we're gonna
radically revise the American bargain I
took he's undercutting his own message
there and then on the second plane he is
I am a return to class in the White
House and decency and all men should be
held accountable and also Tara Reid's a
damned liar and we are going to ignore
everything she has to say and we're
gonna call for due process because now
when it's Joe Biden we want to process
now listen I think the Joe Biden has
every right to say this never happened I
think Joe Biden has every right to
evidence I think Joe Biden has every
right to suggest that people ought to
hold people to a process of evidence in
due process standards I think that's all
right
I'm just finding it kind of ironic that
everybody in the me2 movement holds that
standard for Joe Biden but for nobody
else so here is the the first prong of
this Joe Biden did a today a little bit
of a an endorsement video with Hillary
Clinton yesterday he had her on his
silly podcast and from his from his
basement and he says he's gonna go to
her for advice which is probably the
worst thing you can do Hillary gives
very bad advice she thanked him by the
way for doing this from his for being
able to talk with him from his basement
no the last time Hillary Clinton was in
a basement was with a wrench and Jeffrey
Epstein was there in any case here was
here was Joe Biden saying he's gonna
keep calling Hillary for advice which is
pretty much the worst thing you can do
in a presidential election you want to
thank Hillary for joining us in this
conversation today and Hillary I'm going
to keep call and asking for your advice
the coronavirus is a shining a bright
light on the equities in our country and
there's so much work to do but I have no
doubt we can meet these challenges
brought on by this virus if we work
together by the way he actually did seem
to be following asleep while talking to
Hillary Clinton that was pretty funny do
we have that clip it's pretty it's
pretty hilarious women in our country
has been classified as essential so this
is an issue that affects all of us
young and old Joe Joe hey there Joe Joe
Joe I assume he's just looking down at
his notes or something but it looks very
much as though Joe Biden has gone
comatose but the the first prong again
is that he's going to propose radical
solutions at the same time claiming that
he has a return to status quo anthe here
he was yesterday with Hillary and
Hillary was saying we can achieve health
justice from this crisis basically the
rahm emanuel thing right it's a crisis
and if we didn't achieve health justice
on the back of a pandemic we would be
blowing the opportunity pandemics are
not opportunities pandemics are
catastrophes to treat a catastrophe as
an opportunities to be a bad person
here's Hillary this would be a terrible
crisis to waste as the old saying goes
we've learned a lot about what our
absolute frailties are in our country
when it comes to health justice and
economic justice so you know let's be
resolved that we're gonna solve those
once you're elected president okay
that's it that's amazing like she's
openly this is why he'll already such a
bad politician by the way she just
openly says this stuff and she says the
quiet part out loud we should never let
a good crisis go to waste you know like
you know 75,000 Americans dying that's a
great opportunity for us to completely
bankrupt our private health care system
that has been extraordinarily responsive
it's a great opportunity for us to do
Medicare for all which has been working
perfectly in France and the UK and in
Italy all of which have nationalized
health care systems and all of which
have a worse rate of death per million
than the United States by the way so
that is prong number one then there is
prong number two which is the media and
Democrats completely downplaying the me
to questions about Joe Biden so again I
will say I actually do not find Tara
Reid's allegations particularly credible
usually there's a pattern of conduct
when people do this sort of stuff
also there are serious questions about
the timeline and she says she found the
Senate report that Senate report seems
to be missing in action but we now know
that Tara Reid's mom called in to Larry
King
we know that the Tara Reid told a bunch
of people who were around her about this
allegation which is more contemporaneous
evidence than Christine Blasi Ford ever
provided it is hilarious hilarious to
watch the Democrats pretzel themselves
on this thing I mean it really is
incredible so let's take for example
this feminist meets who leader the meets
who found her name is Tarana Burke right
here is what she tweeted about this I
took a moment away from work and
movement related issues to be present
where I was needed as my family was
affected with Kovan but I know many of
you are wondering about my take on the
Tara Reid story one out of 14 no nothing
like that a long Twitter thread my
stance has never
waivered survivors have a right to speak
their truth and be given the space to
heal the inconvenient truth is that this
story is impacting us differently
because it hits at the heart of one of
the most important elections of our
lifetime and I hate to disappoint you
but I don't really have easy answers oh
don't you oh don't you weird because I
have a feeling if these allegations were
made about Donald Trump and they were
you would not be well you know this
impacts the election I have some serious
concerns says there are no perfect
survivors and no one especially a
presidential candidate is beyond
reproach so where does that leave us
where does that leave us in just world
we'd have a transformative approach to
dealing with claims of sexual violence
where a survivor story is given fair
consideration and they are made whole by
a process that supports both
accountability and healing that's a lot
of words that be nothing well done there
this is doubly important when outsized
power dynamics are involved but we don't
have that right now I thought that's
what you were fighting before no like
wouldn't now be like a great time for
you to stand up for just what we have
now is a zero-sum game or absolutely no
one wins really does no one win because
if what you stood up for words believe
all women you'd be out there on the
ramparts shouting about Joe Biden being
a molester in part because most people
weighing in at the moment don't actually
care about transforming a culture of
sexual violence ah there we go
when it when your argument is bad then
the first thing you should do is impugn
the motives of people who are making the
counter-argument right when when your
argument is bad
definitely impugn the motives of people
covering it the story is not that a
woman came out and accused can we say
credibly accused when do we get to use
credibly accused it was because that was
the word with Christine blaze credibly
accused and I kept using credibly
accused long after her story completely
fall apart credibly accused okay so we
can't say incredibly accused about Tara
Reid for some reason and then I love the
fact that she's like well you know we
can't trust people who are asking
questions because their motives are bad
oh because the motives of people asking
about Brett Kavanaugh were absolutely
great the same people who are saying
they wouldn't vote for Brett Kavanaugh
if their if their choice were voting for
Brett Kavanaugh being thrown into a
flaming hot lava pit those same people
their motives were absolutely pure in
taking Christine Blasi forward at face
value to run a Burk me two founders as
many of you are only interested in this
story because you are entertained by the
trauma of others or because it has the
potential to be politically expedient
with no real regard for the survivor
weird because if you had regard for the
survivor it seems like you'd be taking
her story super seriously but right now
it seems like you're kind of dismissing
her story cuz you like Joe Biden isn't
that really what's going on here isn't
this variation of
Nina brulee argument that was made in
1998 during the Lewinsky scandal
machinable a who is I believe writing
for Time magazine at the time said that
she would do what Lewinsky did to keep
abortion legal tirana Brooke says on the
one hand Tara Reed has been afforded the
opportunity to speak her truth through
mainstream media reporting on her claims
and ongoing investigative journalism has
she though cuz no one's had her on MSNBC
nobody's had her on CNN the New York
Times made one report on it on April
12th and that's it really was that the
fair shake she should have been able to
come forward in a process where she was
treated fairly in a trusted system
instead like other public survivors
before her she had to rely on
journalists in order to be heard
precisely because the system for
survivors are not in place you know she
should have gone to is utoronto birth
and then maybe you should become of her
out of it you're the me to lady you're
the me to lady and you're like well you
know this is a complicated issue I find
it very difficult to believe that
surronded birth would find this quite so
complicated if her political interests
were not impune here she's on the other
hand the defense of Joe Biden shouldn't
rest on whether he's a good guy or our
only hope instead he could demonstrate
what it looks like to be both
accountable and electable oh is that is
that how meaning at a minimum
acknowledging that his demonstrated
learning curve around boundaries with
women at the very least left him open
left him open to all of this right love
it
no omit and then she continues she
continues no matter what you believe we
are allowed to expect more of the person
president running for president of the
United States this is where we are we
don't have a guidebook for this in part
because it would take a willingness from
all of us to write it survivors deserve
more than being used as a political
football by disinterested parties and a
culture of acknowledging harm can't
exist if we continue to view sexual
violence as a catastrophic outlier
rather than an embedded toxic element
America so basically that is I'm not
gonna condemn Joe Biden because I like
Joe Biden and I want him to be the
president speaking of people who want to
Biden to be the president Stacey Abrams
so Justin Amash announced he's gonna run
for president my friend Seth Manziel had
the best suite on this he said
immediately Stacey Abrams sends her
application because Stacey Abrams is
unemployed at the moment and she's
desperate to be the vice president and
Joe Biden apparently is taking a look at
her mainly because he has some pretty
bad numbers among black Americans
shockingly Donald Trump actually has cut
into the black vote chair so Stacey
Abrams told The Huffington Post in an
email I believe women deserve to be
heard I believe that has happened here
the allegations have been heard and
looked into for too many women often
that's not the case
the New York Times conducted a thorough
investigation nothing in The Times
review or any other later reports
suggest anything other than what I
already know about Joe Biden and he will
make women proud as the next president
of the United States and then she
doubled down on that she said no I don't
have a double standard
with Joe Biden Brett Kavanaugh no double
standard whatsoever so she said on CNN
that she there's no double standard here
no noble Justin no double standard at
all she says not at all I believe then I
believe now women deserve to be heard
because too often they are not and Tara
Reid deserve to have her story listen to
and investigated what was happening to
Kristine Blasi for was there was no
investigation there was no investigation
they went and interviewed witnesses
there was a rush to move it forward so
no investigation was conducted
they literally delayed the vote on Brett
Kavanaugh by a full weeks of the FBI
could conduct an investigation you
remember this Jeff Flake delayed the
vote for a week
I believe those allegations needed to be
investigated I believe the New York
Times and subsequent reports support
what the Biden campaign said I believe
Joe Biden so maybe that has more to do
with Stacey Abrams wanting to be his VP
candidate the best here the best is
Kirsten Gillibrand so Kirsten Gillibrand
who is just a human bag of play-doh able
to take any form she originally ran as a
conservative Democrat in New York who is
pro gun and had questions about abortion
and now she's running as she ran for
president as intersectional warrior on
the ramparts of radical culture slay
Queen so Kirsten Gillibrand the crap
senator from New York who basically came
out against Al Franken and forced him to
step down over allegations that he was
grabbing women's boobs while they were
asleep right and then she also came out
against Brett Kavanaugh and suggested
his life should be ruined because of all
this and she said that if she'd been
around in politics in like the late 90s
then she probably should have she
probably would have gone up against the
Clintons and should have told the
Clintons that bill needed to leave it
does after Hillary Clinton supported her
and after she took all of their support
now Kristin Sheila brands like you know
who needs to process Joe Biden
so Bill Clinton under the bus because he
was no longer useful Brett Kavanaugh
can't be on the Supreme Court because
they were unverified and uh neva densed
allegations against him and also we need
to make sure that Al Franken leaves the
Senate but you know who's the best Joe
Biden Kirsten Gillibrand is just my it
has there ever been a more transparently
ridiculous politician than Kirsten
Gillibrand I'm not sure what's going
what's going in the water in New York
between Cuomo and Gillibrand and a blah
you folks need a better class of
criminal here's Kirsten Gillibrand when
we say believe women it's for this
explicit intention of making sure
there's space for all women to come
forward to speak their truth to be heard
and in this allegation that is what Tara
Reid has done and she has come forward
she's spoken and they've done an
investigation in several outlets I stand
by Vice President Biden he's devoted his
life to supporting women and he has been
Legion I had this allegation well that
is um that is a that is a an amazing
shift in position there Kirsten
Gillibrand and I would be surprised by
that except that you play political
twister basically every single day which
is why you got zero votes in the
Democratic primaries for president one
of the one most lovely things was
watching Kirsten Gillibrand twist
herself into a gender studies major to
Wellesley in order to run for president
and then completely fall in on herself
like a dying star that was those pretty
delicious it is even more delicious to
watch as she sells out her final
principle the me2 movement in order to
back Joe Biden to maybe grab a crumb of
maybe like that cabinet position he'll
make her Secretary of Housing and Urban
Development Kirsten Gillibrand
ridiculous ridiculous stuff will any of
this end up costing but I get the
feeling this is snowballing a little bit
and that the double standard is gonna be
bad for Joe Biden remember people are
saying well he can just shout Trump I'm
just out tripper cuz Trump has a really
bad history with women okay he can try
it there's only one problem and this is
what Hillary discovered in 2016 Donald
Trump is a mud monster the man is made
of mud if you throw him out of Donald
Trump you know what he looks the same as
he did before he is still a mud monster
if you throw mud in a mud monster he now
just has more mud on him if you throw
mud at your Biden and Joe Biden has been
portrayed as pure as the driven snow is
clean and as white as a freshly spread
bed sheet that's gonna show a lot more
and it's gonna be a problem for Joe
Biden changing the perception of a
politician is much more dangerous than
reinforcing a perception of a politician
so that is a weird thing stand in 2020
with regard to Joe Biden we'll be back a
little bit later today with two hours of
additional content otherwise we will see
you here tomorrow for much much more i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Colton Haas directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling assistant director Pavel
Whitehouse key technical producer Austin
Stephens playback and media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam SCI events audio
is mixed by Mike foramina hair and
makeup is by Anika geneva the ben
shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 California
Governor Gavin Newsom is ready to reopen
shops and schools but churches are
staying closed for the foreseeable
future
the reopen plans tell us a lot about the
state of American Psycho society then
Joe Biden gets a big endorsement from
the woman who spent decades smearing all
of Bill Clinton's sexual victims China
faces a new consequences for inflicting
this virus on us and a surprise
candidate enters the race for president
all that more check it out on the
Michael Noel's show
you